today we ring in the lunar new year and
a perfect way to celebrate the year the
tiger is with cocktails here to give us
a demonstration this is daniel yang from
the elektra cocktail club at the
venetian how's it going buddy going well
jc thank you for having us thanks for
being here now you guys have multiple
different cocktails at the venetian what
are some of the drinks that you guys are
offering thank you for highlighting that
we do offer one of our specialty chinese
new year cocktails at each of our venues
from the cocktail collective for here we
have our spicy
longevity for the rosina and then we
also offer the lunar lantern at the
dorsey now how often these will be
offered through the month of february
how long does these specials go for
we'll be offering these until february
12th okay and then what's the drink that
you guys have well today we're going to
be showcasing our uh tiger blossom carto
for electric cocktail club inside the
venetian resorts
and we're basically going to be talking
about what makes it special and what
flavors to expect from it what do we
well first off check out look at this
what do you call that ice cube where do
you get an ice cube that long like that
that is perfect so i mean you can make
these at home but we typically buy them
from a third party they are called ice
spears so the more surface area you have
and ice the faster it melts so we're
trying to reduce that and have a longer
lasting cocktail that tastes fresh
longer okay what goes in this thing so
what's so special about our version of
the chinese new york cocktail is we're
actually doing collins variations with
fresh strawberries that we're going to
lightly muddle to extract the flavors
fresh lemon juice house made simple
syrup and cognac daniel let's get to it
let's start making one sounds good i
want to see i want to see you i want to
see you in action right here buddy well
so for the sake of brevity we're
actually going to pre-batch them a
little bit for you guys here
we're going ahead and have two ounces of
our cognac and as you're making the
drink here talk about some other things
that are happening at the venetian
because there's a lot going on in
regards to the chinese new year so for
the chinese new year we like to try to
offer as many different possible
celebrations as you know
inside the venetian doing their own
specialty offerings as well you can find
all of this online at
venetianlasvegas.com
and if you have any other questions you
know i'll be electra so you can ask me
directly you're the guy to go see you
guys i'm drinking i love it and then you
also have like a tiger installation
there as well yes it's going to be in
the waterfall atrium so it's a great
area for a photo ops if you're looking
to instagram it's all about exactly the
social media social cloud you know
that's where we're all chasing these
things that's right we got about 30
seconds let's get this dream all right
let's go
the shake oh there
look at the daniel go
quick shake a little effervescence to
brighten it up and there's a little side
note as far as the fever tree is that is
that like the preferred like cocktail
mix of bartenders uh we definitely
prefer it over our cocktail collective
it's wonderful in terms of highlighting
the what we call um exclusive flavors
that you'll see yeah it adds a lot of
effervescence without taking away from
the flavor because i see a lot of people
using the fever tree when it comes to
either clump soda or tonic so yes
all right we're gonna top that off
more strawberry muddle the fresh
strawberry you guys use all fresh fruits
in your drinks over there always perfect
the secret ingredient can i give us a
taste of course please start the new
year right let's give it a shot
ah that's good driver that is good one
more time
with the website uh yes venetian las
vegas dot com all right well happy happy
new year
what's in that drink i can't even talk
daniel my gosh
thanks man i appreciate it thank you
jillian we'll send it over to you thank
you jc well